there is some cause for tentative
optimism in these jobs figures but there
are also challenges ahead as we move
through into the autumn so first this is
the number of people in payroll jobs you
can see that big dip there as the
pandemic hit and those figures gradually
recovering this year the estimates for
august are that 29.1
million people are now in paye jobs
that's back to pre-pandemic levels now
that's obviously good news but we should
be cautious about this the unemployment
rate is still higher than it was and we
don't yet know how many more people will
be looking for work when that furlough
scheme ends
but this is what will be really worrying
some businesses despite more people
being back in jobs the number of
vacancies is now the highest it's been
at any point since records began and
while this might be not a bad thing for
workers we know it's causing supply
chain delays and it's increasingly
difficult for small business owners
amikay is one of them he runs a
restaurant and he's struggling to find
the extra four staff he needs
we're looking for positions as uh you
know waitresses and restaurant
supervisors
um kitchen assistants um sous chefs
so it's kind of right through the the
the hierarchy levels you just don't have
the number of team members that we need
um to in the hours and days that we
would like to
now vacancies are being largely driven
by certain key sectors as you can see
many thousands of people are needed in
sectors like social and health in the
wholesale and retail sector and in
others as well but the real question is
whether all of these available jobs can
or will be filled by people who are
still unemployed or unfurloughed and
that is by no means guaranteed now these
new bars in color over the top there
show the number of furloughed people in
each of those sectors and as you can see
in parts of the economy there are
actually more people who need jobs than
there are jobs available that implies
the jobs are perhaps not in the right
place or at the right level for the
workers and it may well be harder to
find a new job depending on where you
live as you can see the unemployment
rate varies significantly across the
country as high as six percent in london
and as low as 3.3 percent in the
southwest given that london also has the
highest number of people on furlough
there could be significant competition
for jobs there what's clear is that the
pandemic has changed the economy forever
as it realigns both employers and
employees will have to adapt